[MUSIC]
I think I would go as far
back to say it was when I was
doing my undergrad thesis.
I was learning about the effects
of language loss and
its toll that it has
taken on my identity.
Being Miwok and not knowing
the language or the traditions,
it really felt I don't know the word for
it could be, you know inadequate.
You know I don't know much about my
heritage, my culture and I want to
know more and I want to be able to pass
that knowledge down to my children.
So I started looking into basket
weaving a little bit of the language.
I started interviewing my
grandmother and my mother and
trying to get as much information I
could from my closest family members.
[MUSIC]
But then I found a website that was
built by one of the tribal members, and
it had certain audio clips of counting,
and colors, and things like that.
And I started playing
with it with my son and
we would click on the numbers and
before I would click the next one,
wait let me try to say it so
I can see if I can say it right and
it just went from like a game
that my son and I played.
And I wanted to do more with that and
I figured that a lot of families are
kind of in the same situation we are.
We're in the Bay Area,
which is about two hours away
from the tribal community.
And if there are more people
who are far enough away,
it's not accessible to them, so
let's bring the language to the people.